do it anyway is a mindset trick that you
can use when you start to feel excuses
rolling up it works a lot like the five
second rule you have said to yourself
okay I'm gonna talk to my boss today
about that thing that I've been avoiding
talking to them about and then the
moment comes where you've got to have
that conversation or the moment comes
where it's time to pack up your bag and
leave your desk and go to the gym and
what always happens you don't feel like
it I bet there are plenty of you
watching that have made a commitment
that I'm not going to have a drink
tonight and then guess what happens when
you get home you don't feel like not
drinking you feel like having a drink
here's what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that I just do it anyway has
pushed me to realize and to recognize
that there are a lot of moments when
there are things in my life that I
really want to do I need to do but when
the moment comes I don't feel like it
and so I pull out this idea of you know
what I'm just gonna do it anyway it's
raining outside I said I would go for a
short run I don't feel like it I'm gonna
do it anyway it's six o'clock in the
morning I'm tired it's cold I laid out
my yoga clothes but now I don't feel
like it what do I do I do it anyway when
you start to say to yourself I'm gonna
do it anyway what happens is something
really cool you acknowledge that there
are feelings that you have that are
trying to swoop in and hijack you and
you basically say guess what I'm gonna
do it anyway hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I was making 300 bucks a
month I quit on my business partner and
the thing that saved me was studying the
stories of super successful
entrepreneurs so I hope that this story
today helps give you the motivation you
need because I still needed to myself so
today let's learn the steps you can take
to change your life enjoy
step number two is develop unconditional
love with Lewis house this is something
that a lot of people are afraid to do
and that is to embrace your flaws and
develop unconditional self-love this is
challenging leadership and productivity
expert Rory Vaden has studied and spoken
about the psychology behind
procrastination for years now and during
one of our interviews together he told
me that the single biggest reason we
procrastinate is that we don't feel like
we're good enough we're smart enough or
capable enough of doing the thing we
want to accomplish so to cope with that
reality we self-sabotage by not even
starting now this is a big deal because
most of my life I didn't feel like I was
good enough smart enough talented enough
old enough experienced enough credible
enough to go out and do the things that
I've done and so it is scary it's hard
to overcome that insecurity that fear
that self-doubt and so therefore a lot
of times people will procrastinate
because of that but that's the thing the
space in between the doubt and where you
want to be is the experience you need to
gain it's the the skills you need to
acquire it's the fears you need to
overcome in order to get there so that
is the thing that we've got to learn to
do now I also thought this point that
Rory shared was so powerful and we've
seen a ton of positive feedback from
listeners about how eye-opening it was
for them as well and maybe you've had a
dream of writing a screenplay for years
but you didn't feel like you're talented
enough for anyone to buy it so you
self-sabotage by not even starting maybe
you've wanted to launch a business since
you were a kid but you don't think
anyone would ever buy your product or
service so again you self-sabotage by
convincing your yourself it's not worth
your time now to get you moving in the
right direction I want to share two
powerful exercises that will help you
develop unconditional self-love to get
you through these types of negative
thoughts that holds so many people back
and the first one comes from former Navy
SEAL and best-selling author David
Goggins and he calls it the cookie jar
concept to start I want you to think of
three accomplishments that you are most
proud of in your life and maybe it's
moving to another state or country or
maybe it's finding a way to thrive in a
new place or maybe it's something that
seems as simple as starting a book
you've always wanted to read but you
kept putting it off and now you finished
it these moments are what will go into
your cookie jar so be sure to remember
them or write them down if you need to
write down what these accomplishments
are then whenever you're having a bad
day or you think you don't have what it
takes to finish a difficult task I want
you to look inside your cookie jar are
and anytime doubt creeps into your head
reach for your cookie jar and repeat
those accomplishments out loud to
yourself this will help remind you that
you are capable of reaching the goals in
front of you so if you consistently get
up in the morning and run then three
months down the line you'll know in your
heart of hearts that you are a runner
the second exercise comes from a
framework that I put together with my
team and it's called the abundance
formula and to begin I want you to take
a moment to write down the answers to
the question I'm going to ask you right
now so on a scale of one to ten how much
gratitude do you put out into the world
and give to yourself essentially what
rating would you give yourself when it
comes to showing a general sense of
gratitude on a consistent basis in the
world you're grateful for life you're
grateful for the people that you
interact with you're grateful for the
basic things for the big things you're a
grateful person on a scale of one to ten
ten being the highest that you just live
and breathe gratitude all day long one
being the lowest second part on a scale
of one to ten how much do you appreciate
the person you are and the people in
your life what grade would you give
yourself on the self appreciation scale
so 10 being I really appreciate myself
and I appreciate people around me by
communicating that appreciation Ken
being very high one being you never
appreciate anyone else or yourself and
last on a scale from one to ten how
regularly do you acknowledge the person
you've become and do you acknowledge
other people how often do you take time
to acknowledge the obstacles you've
overcome in your life however big or
small they might be to you again 10
being you acknowledge yourself and
others consistently one being you never
acknowledge yourself for what you've
overcome or who you've been how do you
expect to be someone who was
consistently having energy focus and the
passion to show up for their dreams if
you can't even show up for yourself if
you can't take the time on a regular
basis to acknowledge yourself for being
the person you are then how do you
expect to have the self-love necessary
to overcome procrastination and
challenges if you can't take the time to
appreciate and be grateful for who you
are how do you expect to know that
you're worthy of a better life this is
such an important and impactful exercise
because the truth is that chasing after
your dreams on a regular basis is
already an uphill battle and not having
a firm foundation of self-worth will
make it an even tougher climb I also
know another truth though we're all
worthy of loving ourselves
unconditionally no matter where you're
out of your journey no matter what
mistakes you've made no matter where
you've been or what others have said to
you we all have what it takes to
overcome the doubts that are holding us
back and keeping us from going after our
hopes and dreams step number three is
get to know yourself with sad Guru it's
going to be introduced that's all
you're paying too much attention to
everything around you not enough
attention to this one but the quality of
your life is essentially determined by
how you carry this one
yes or no
this moment
what kind of clothes you're wearing
what kind of card you parked outside
what kind of home you live in does not
determine the quality of your life this
moment how joyful are you feeling within
yourself determines the quality of your
life isn't it so
nothing has been done about it you think
it will happen in consequence
and you're setting impossible goals for
your happiness if I have to be happy my
wife should be like this my husband
should be like that my children should
be like this the world should become
some other way
well these are impossible conditions
you're setting for your happiness and
peacefulness
now that you have compromised yourself
to peace
why I'm saying compromise yourself to
Pieces because a lot of people have
given up aspirations for being ecstatic
or Blissful if I'm just peaceful it's
enough
even the so-called spiritual leaders are
going about and saying peace is the
highest goal in your life
peace is not the highest goal in your
life if you want to enjoy your lunch
today you must be peaceful
this one
if you're not even peaceful there is
nothing in your life that you can do in
a worthwhile way
to be peaceful essentially means this
that you're not messing your mind
to be peaceful means
that your system is at ease
you know how to conduct your mind you
know how to conduct your emotions your
body and your energies you are peaceful
it is not a rocket technology
it is the most basic thing you have a
dog at home you give him his food he
sits peacefully
maybe not ecstatic but peacefully many
times they're ecstatic also
yes
if your dog is able to sit please oh he
doesn't have to run my industry
that's not the point he's got his own
stuff going
[Music]
see it has nothing to do with the
external activity that you're doing it's
got something to do with the internal
systems as to how they're functioning
essentially it means either neither your
body nor your mind or your Chemistry nor
your emotions nor your energy or taking
instructions from you they're doing
their own thing
once your machine is not in your control
being peaceful is impossible I'll tell
you you get into your car and now you go
there and you want to turn this way you
do this to the steering it goes this way
can you peacefully drive this car
can you no anxiety is natural isn't it
this is what has happened to your
vehicle it's out of control
you've never done anything to find out
where the steering wheel is first of all
this is not that simple as a car this is
a super super computer now the problem
is most people have not even bothered to
find the keyboard
they think if they do this somehow it
will work
if you make when you're given such a
highly sophisticated machine if you do
not conduct it properly it will cause
many problems to you
by accident it's working I want you to
know this this is made this way if you
hold your hands like this it'll breathe
one way if you just turn it around the
very way you breathe the breathing
pattern itself changes in your lungs you
can try it if you want when you have the
time this way this way I am saying
everything that you do
fundamental changes are happening in
this machine because it's such a
sophisticated machine
it's more than a touch screen if you
just wish it it will happen
when you have such a sensitive and
sophisticated machine and you are
operating like a blacksmith
then being peaceful seems to be
difficult
peace is not the highest goal in your
life it is the most fundamental
requirement don't ever set peace as the
highest goal if you do that you will
only rest in peace
[Laughter]
you must see to be peaceful is the first
thing in your life isn't it if you want
to do anything sensibly in your life
if you want to do conduct any situation
in your life sensibly to be peaceful and
happy is fundamental such a fundamental
thing is rising to Heavens these days
people think they are going to be
peaceful somewhere else not here
because you have never paid attention to
this machine
never paid attention to the internal
mechanism of how a human being functions
what is the basis of everything that's
happening within you it takes a little
bit of attention that's why our basic
program is called as inner engineering
we have engineered the whole world the
way we want it much comfort and
convenience has come but well-being is
not come isn't it because well-being
will not come well-being will come only
when this is engineered the way you want
it only then you will know well-being
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there Step number four is learn to
prioritize with David Meltzer 100 of the
things you do now get done
if you do things now it takes half as
much time and you're exponentially more
successful
prioritization prioritization
into procrastination I know when
somebody knows where they're going
because they know how to prioritize they
know how to make those decisions they
know what's valuable to them they have
their non-negotiables family health
activity I get paid for every day I put
times on those minimum of an hour a day
on my health minimum of 30 minutes with
my wife every day minimum 30 minutes
with my 11 year old son minimum two
minutes a day with my teenage daughters
I asked for five they gave me two they
can give you a negotiation class
how about this one minimum of a minute a
day minimum right people give me [ __ ] on
the internet because they don't listen
they're like you only spend two minutes
with your daughters no I want more it's
a minimum every day two minutes a day is
worth more than two hours on a Saturday
I promise you aggregate effect study
Einstein compound interest aggregate
effect of good habits and bad habits not
just money
it compounds its own interest
takes 90 percent of the effort to even
see a result so what happens when we
have good habits
is we expect instant results so we quit
what happens when we have bad habits we
don't expect to have a result so we get
to 90 percent down the road and wonder
why we have drug and alcohol problems
depression and anxiety and interference
in our life because we've let it
aggregate into itself
know you're now prioritize what you want
who can help and how to get it done you
will be so productive accessible and
gracious you'll be amazed at the
aggregate effect and compound interest
in your life step number five is create
your winning image with Bob Proctor we
were created to have and enjoy all the
good that life has to offer you're God's
greatest creation and you are meant to
win
unfortunately not everyone views the
world or their life the same way some
see it as a very harsh cool world and
they're forever struggling to make ends
meet or keep a relationship together it
seems they're forever running on a
treadmill going nowhere never taking the
time to enjoy what they have or to see
the beauty of the world that they're a
part of
you ever asked yourself what
differentiates the winners from the
masses well I have I've researched the
subject now for over a quarter of a
century and I have found that the
winners are aware of a certain place
within it's referred to as the higher
self and in this higher self there's an
image of perfection which is forever
attempting to express itself in a
greater way when the winner wants to
turn their dreams into physical
realities they call on this higher self
now generally when a person doesn't know
how to do something they say they can't
do it the truth is they can you and I
are capable of doing anything we are
God's greatest creation we're Spiritual
Beings and as Spiritual Beings we're
able to do anything at all all things
are possible our objective is to figure
out how not whether we're able to or not
to properly deposit your winning image
in the treasury of your subconscious
mind it's vitally important that you
remember the first law of learning it's
repetition
begin to visualize yourself with some of
the nice things you'd like to have
possibly the home that you'd like to
live in it may be the business you want
to build or the position you'd like to
hold possibly the income you'd like to
earn you may want to visualize the
vacation that you'd like to take
what is important is that you do
visualize block out any distractions let
yourself totally relax and begin to see
yourself actually living the life that
you imagined yourself living see
yourself the winner that you want to be
and let all these beautiful pictures
sink deep into every cell of your being
in other words add a lot of emotion to
it something as simple as how you
address and how you walk and how you
project yourself sends a strong message
to everyone in your external world but
it also sends a very powerful message to
your subconscious mind
present yourself physically in a manner
that's consistent with this new winning
image that you're developing
then we want to go inside take a real
close look at ourselves with our Inner
Eye of understanding how do we perceive
ourselves are we beginning to see
ourselves from within as the winner that
we really want to be and you'll know and
realize that you've created a better
world for yourself and everyone else to
enjoy and you'll also realize that what
you're looking at is a reflection of
your own winning image step number six
is maximize productivity with Brian
Tracy I started my quest to find the
best techniques for maximizing
productivity a long time ago for years
and years I asked the most successful
people I knew the same question what is
it about you that makes you more
productive than everyone else
and guess what happened they told me
everything they knew all I had to do was
simply ask and as they were telling me
their greatest productivity habits I
took notes on everything that they said
now I can confidently say that using
their productivity techniques changed my
life for the better actually it changed
my life forever
I it didn't take long before I started
to experience the results I wanted
these productivity techniques are so
powerful so effective and so
life-changing
I've been sharing them with the world
wherever I can over the years
usually this is during the middle of an
interview or when I'm privately
Consulting with a client but now I'm
sharing them with you
the first productivity tip I'm going to
share today is simple but highly
effective in order to be productive
Prime yourself for success by believing
that you can be productive and putting
yourself in a winning environment
you can do this by making sure that your
space is clear and tidy and a pleasant
place to be
gather all the materials needed to
succeed in your tasks and be productive
if you have everything that you need
easily at hand you won't have to waste
time looking for these items later
decorating your office or other space
with inspiring colors good smelling
plants and other items may also be
helpful this will help Foster creativity
and allow you to be more productive
while you work
my second tip to stay productive is to
plan ahead
surprise can be the enemy to
productivity
avoid throwing yourself for a loop when
something unexpected happens
remember that unexpected things are
still going to take place and while it
may be hard to plan specifically for
something that you don't know will
happen planning for the things you can
control will help you to prioritize and
stay on track to be more productive
try planning out your tasks for the
morning when you wake up at lunchtime
you can re-evaluate how much you've
gotten done so far and whether anything
unexpected has come up in your day
then plan out your afternoon and evening
so that you can continue being
productive The Next Step that helps
myself and others and hopefully now you
is to to find productivity is to build
manageable habits when you create a
realistic manageable routine for
yourself it's so much easier to
cultivate an environment and mindset
that will enable you and allow you to be
more productive
there's no need to come up with a
complicated routine full of bells and
whistles you really only need to cut out
anything that isn't necessary and focus
on the tasks you actually need to do
immediately
keeping things simple will enable you to
complete the tasks that matter more
quickly and efficiently
my fourth productivity tip for you is to
prioritize learn and move on
I recommend using the ABCDE method to
boost productivity this method is a way
to sort things into categories
here's how it works a stands for your
most important tasks things that should
be your top priority
b stands for tasks that come with minor
consequences if they don't get done but
they're not major
C stands for tasks that don't have
consequences they need to be done but
there's no need to rush phoning a friend
you know bleeding some mailing things
like that detests are things that you
should delegate give these tasks to
someone else delegate everything that
you possibly can to free up time to do
those things that only you can do
e items should be eliminated from your
list
their entire teaching systems that show
you how to eliminate unnecessary tasks
so you have more and more time to those
do those things that are more valuable
than anything else
learning how to prioritize is a huge
secret to becoming more productive if
you fail to correctly prioritize your
to-do list don't get down on yourself
take responsibility for any failures
then identify your weaknesses and work
on turning them into strength
my final tip to help you stay productive
and achieve your goals is to make every
minute count
consider using the 80 20 rule here this
rule states that twenty percent of your
activities account for eighty percent of
your results
when it comes to productivity it's often
true that your most productive 20 of the
day produces eighty percent of your
results and your successes
you can put this rule into practice by
figuring out the time of day when you
tend to be the most productive then
prioritize and work on your most
important tasks during that time and
step number seven the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is develop
self-acceptance with Brendan burchard if
you don't have self-acceptance clearly
you don't have authentic self-confidence
if you don't have self acceptance
clearly you won't have an authentic
sense of happiness because you don't
even like yourself
so what do we do about this when I'm
coaching others well first after I've
tried to understand where that's coming
from that solution driven part of
coaching is about realizing there's
things we all do to gain greater
self-acceptance your self
wants to realize itself
right we all want to reach a fuller
higher standard of our potential right
we we all want that we I've never met a
person in my life who didn't want to
realize a higher level of potential for
themselves or their family or their
teams or their work and I know some of
you like no no you don't know my kid
he's 42 and he's still on the couch I
don't have a judgment for that what I
have to say about that is this
that person does too
it's built in the human spirit
we all want to grow
we all want to be happy
sometimes we get discouraged from that
enough
that we lie to ourselves and say we
don't want it or worse
we don't deserve it
many people don't have self-acceptance
because they don't believe they deserve
it
they think that they did something wrong
they had other people judge them
they had that experience when they've
had so much negativity around them they
started to believe that story
and so what I share with you about
self-acceptance
um it's one of the reasons I'm a very
big proponent of coaching or of therapy
a lot of self-acceptance is actually
socially gained
you know there's a reason that the
psychology department tends to be in the
same building as a sociology Department
because they go hand in hand we are
social animals a lot of your acceptance
of yourself actually has nothing to do
with self-acceptance your acceptance
yourself came from how people treated
you before it was socially gained and
constrained
you started to believe that you were at
a certain level based on how other
people around you treated you isn't true
in one way
to gain greater self-acceptance is to
take back that self part and say oh I'm
gonna do the work on me right now
I'm going to take some time to work on
myself again and I am going to lessen
the noise of the negative people around
me and get around positive people who
amplify the noise of positivity
it doesn't mean get around yes persons
it means get around yes spirited persons
people who are supportive and
encouraging of you you probably have one
positive friend talk to them more often
hang out with them more often lean on
them more
I think that's critical
because the easiest way to develop off
in the self is in our social environment
getting other more positive healthy
people around us tends to lift all boats
the other thing to think about with the
acceptance part
is to learn
to be in the moment in such a way that
you can forgive the things you did in
the past
I don't know if you've picked up on it
yet
but the world is turning a new chapter
you should too
I don't know if you picked up on it but
this is a time of ripe transition and
transformation
allow that for yourself
yeah maybe you screwed up last year in
the business maybe you screwed up four
years ago maybe you did something that
you feel like was Unforgivable
in this moment right here in Your Heart
of Heart in the universe
you got a clean slate
and it is time to start adjusting
from who you were
to who you desire to become
you need to get off the guilt train
and on the becoming train
that old story that chapter closed the
new story is a bunch of blank pages a
lot of self-acceptance
happens in the orientation towards the
future having something to look forward
to deciding to become somebody or
something that you will be proud of
versus sitting there and going I'm
terrible because of last year that year
that year like ruminating on the old
Stories versus building the new one what
are we going to do
when you feel like you're trapped in a
negative route it's often because you
are replaying past old Stories versus
building the new one
it's a new chapter time can I get an
amen on a weekday with anybody it's like
it is a new chapter time it is a get on
the becoming train it is a like our
self-acceptance is revitalized when you
say oh I'm remaking myself
this time I will be intentional this
time I will do a supportive people this
time I will be disciplined and practiced
about it and all of a sudden you start
feeling better about yourself you want
to feel bad about yourself ruminate on
all the old bad things that happen to
you and all the old bad things you did
before
this is why it's so critical to do
personal development work because it
always leans you towards the future
right it always helps you go oh wait
I've got some blank slates here I got
some new chapters here I got some ways
to revitalize myself as soon as yourself
right as soon as your mind acknowledges
that you are building again
something changes a new energy comes
from within and all of a sudden the next
thing can happen you can be congruent
with that vision of yourself
you cast a new vision of yourself and
you take the habits you do the practices
that help you be congruent with becoming
that self and all of a sudden with
greater congruence towards a future self
your confidence comes back up
it's the easiest way to shift somebody
out of that old mentality or those old
feelings or that low self-esteem into a
higher gear
it's about oh
okay I can acknowledge and I can
appreciate and I can accept that the
life that I've lived has happened
I can accept that everything's not
perfect
I can accept I'm not perfect and neither
are they but I can also accept
that right now in this moment
I can have hope
I can accept that right now in this
moment
I can write some new ideas now I can
accept right now in this moment that
tomorrow I can start changing my mindset
to be happy even if my circumstances
aren't yet there
I was a happy
exuberant enthusiastic loving person
at a time where I was constantly in
physically fights I was broke
and I had almost no hope
for a future that would become what what
my life became like
and yet I decided okay I need
to start living into the vision of who I
can become and who I feel called to
become
because who I feel called to become
isn't this person laying in bed feeling
bad about himself all day even though I
had plenty of reasons to feel bad about
myself I will never say to you you don't
have any reasons to feel bad about
yourself I love spiritual teachers who
can teach that I can't do it but I love
when they do
what I my suggest is like hey
let's just accept ourselves I can accept
that you did bad things in the past
I can also accept that maybe you'll
choose today to shift gears and to start
that forward lean to building the Future
character of who you can really become
that's the hope and the promise and the
beauty and the potential of
self-improvement
you know that's the stuff that we
understand change the world in the world
of philosophy all of a sudden you know
you had from stoicism to Christianity to
all of a sudden you know Rousseau
talking about the idea that we have
Liberty and the ability to improve
ourselves oh wait a minute that's a
hopeful Revolution
and that's sometimes what we need that's
sometimes what we need and also I want
to remind you sometimes that means
getting around more supportive people
sometimes that means hiring yourself a
coach so they can monitor your mindset
and help you build sometimes that means
getting a therapy so they can heal the
old stuff whatever it means it means
that you have the opportunity to do it
and what I encourage all of you to set
as a goal
to feel good about yourself skin
the Dallas Uber driver oh
so as somebody who has gotten into
countless Ubers and some small
percentage of them know who I am and
then of course they start asking
questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
yeah the Uber driver in Dallas that's in
this book
um I get choked up when I think about
him uh an aha I choked up I get choked
up because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day you've got millions and millions of
people that are inspired by empowered by
impacted by your content there are
people out there that use your work as a
lifeline
and it is humbling and what I am
really present to in the work that I'm
putting out and the stuff that I'm
sharing whether it's my failures or the
things that I'm using that are helping
me in my own struggles
is just how much people are holding
themselves back and how much pain people
feel
because most folks know what they dream
about
and what they want
and yet they're spending all of their
time and energy arguing against what
they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
I hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment but it's not
going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going I got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go
I don't know if I'm worth it I don't
know if right now is the right time to
do this I don't think I'm good enough I
failed so many times I can't go through
that door
and that's the problem I want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you and you are
actively arguing against it you're
bringing yourself down you're beating
yourself out like people will cheer for
you and me they won't cheer for
themselves
I'm the same way and so this Uber driver
the story that you're talking about I
get into the car and we start driving
and I'm on the phone as we're driving
and I'm having a conversation with
somebody about this daytime talk show
that I launched which was a dream with
Sony Pictures Television and then uh was
promptly fired after season one it was a
huge failure because we didn't make it
to season two
huge failure in real world terms massive
success when it comes to the timeline of
my life and so I'm talking to this
person about the talk show I hang up the
phone and this Uber driver comes alive
he's like oh my gosh I can't believe
you're in my cab and I'm like why and he
says because I I want to talk to you
about something I think you can help me
and I'm like great how can I help you
and he says I have a dream of being a
oscar-winning uh actor and creating
opportunities for other black and Latino
men to do the same in acting and I'm
like freaking fantastic what the [ __ ]
are you doing in Dallas right yeah the
guy's 25 and so I I go you know the game
is in New York and L.A I mean sure you
can act you can write stuff you can be
here in Dallas but why are you not in La
why are you not in New York and he's
like you're right you're right you're
right I need to move to LA like why not
and he says I have 700 in my bank
account I'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have 700 in a car dude
drop me off and get driving what are you
waiting for and so we have this whole
conversation and I write about it in
this book where I am actively arguing
for his dream and he is actively arguing
against his dream
and what is so sad is throughout this
conversation Tom he's like you're right
700 could get me there you're right I am
only 25. you're right if I keep thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about what I want to be doing I'm not
only going to drive in circles my whole
life is going to spin in circles as I
think about what I want and I don't do
[ __ ] about it and then you are going to
find yourself not at 25 but at 45 or 65
and you're going to be so filled with
regret that you never put a put a bet on
yourself
and so this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
California and me giving him a bunch of
tools that I talk about in this book and
the point of the story is does he move
or not I don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us we do not
know how to do it for ourselves it
dawned on me that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
may be exciting and may release dopamine
the neurochemical that he knows the
reward neurochemical
and uh we feel good because we've taken
on this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain whether it's starting to exercise
or eating better or committing to doing
something that's of benefit to us or
even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain
works is that patterns that have been
repeated over you know months and years
are the dominant patterns in our brain
and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well same
thing is true with our brain and the
neural networks and Pathways so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you are taking to
achieve the results that you want more
and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness especially pay close attention
especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they are comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there are certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand I'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch upgrade your
Knowledge and Skills as you have events
to attend you know to to connect to to
listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results treat yourself
like you matter
talk to yourself like you would your
best friends think about
how you talk to other people you know
think about if you're watching this
video if you're a fan of this channel
you are probably
pouring into so many people you're
giving them love you're giving them
encouragement you're giving them belief
you're telling them they can do anything
right your friends even Tech even
strangers on social media you're
probably telling them that they can do
things right you're believing in them
you're giving them confidence but then
what happens you go home you look in the
mirror and you're just telling yourself
all the reasons why you can't do
something that voice inside your own
head sucks right telling yourself that
you can't make it someone like you is
never going to do it we don't treat
ourselves with the same love of
compassion empathy that we have
for other people you wouldn't talk to
your worst enemy the way that you talk
to yourself and that's a big problem I
think that needs to shift that needs to
change because as long as you keep
talking to yourself
like you're a piece of garbage
then you're never going to accomplish
anything great
we have to start to shift it
I had a whole bunch of issues in how I
talk to myself
I used to say well I'm I'm too shy I'm
too introvert I'm nobody's going to want
to hear my story my message doesn't
matter who am I to go off and do this I
have to have a huge ego even I'm sitting
here filming in a parking lot like I
would I would never do this only only
people with giant egos and
uh loud mouths would ever do that all
right I'm still working to unwind all of
that
but the more you can catch it and the
more you can shift it it allows you to
go off and do great things not just for
yourself but for other people because if
you fast forward
if the way you've been talking to
yourself for the past couple of years
continues to be the way that you talk to
yourself for the rest of your life
nothing changes
so how do we shift how do we get to a
point where hey we're actually seeing
better things about ourselves number one
is you have to catch the voice you know
what is the negative voice what are you
saying to yourself because a lot of it
are just
it's not intentional
you know it's these automatic thoughts
it's a subconscious thoughts you come up
with an idea of what you can do and
immediately you shut yourself down
without even noticing it just it's a
default nature instantly boom no I can't
do that no you suck you can't do that
so what are the negative thoughts that
are coming up in your mind and just
trying to catch it
number two is whatever you want to have
more of you need to create that in your
life you need to create the habits and
routines to have more of it in your life
so for me I want more belief right and I
go through this whole process of how to
figure out your most important core
value or your one word you can pick up
your one word or build the serve it'll
walk you through it
what do you need more of in your life I
need more belief and as much as I'm
trying to spread that to the world with
the videos and everything I make I also
need more of it myself I need more
belief for myself and so what helps me
believe in myself well I try to design a
life and an environment to help bring
that out more so
everything from the outfit that I wear
you know I tell myself I'm a superhero
going to work this is my believe uniform
just like Batman puts on his costume
from what my office looks like and the
pictures on my wall I've got my parents
on my wall and
looking at them reminds me of the
message that my mom would always give me
that I'm Advocate Shirley Carmichael I
could do anything and believe that I can
the videos that I make the the main
channel the top 10 Channel this Channel
all the content that I make is designed
to help me believe in myself more
that's what helps me come alive
um service you know thinking about
how what I'm gonna do will have an
impact on somebody else besides me
helps me have the courage to go off and
Chase down the goals that I have for
myself so what is it that makes you come
alive what do you need more of it in
your life because you're probably not
getting enough of it
right the thing that you need more in
your life you're not you're not getting
enough of it right now that's why that
negative voice is so powerful and
default
so think about the people who you're
hanging around and the media you're
consuming all of it you're not getting
enough of the thing that you need so how
do you get more of that thing and
engineer and design it so that it's part
of your daily calendar that's not
randomly happening in your life but it's
with intent
must happen every day
so number one is catching that horse
what is that voice
number two is designing that environment
and the habits and the routines for
yourself so that you're around it
constantly you're changing our
environment to be around the thing that
you know that you want to be and then
number three is
Empower people to pull you out of the
Matrix you know Empower people to call
you out Empower people to give you
feedback
some of my favorite ways to do it
uh whenever I'm going to an event or
whatever I'm talking to somebody I
respect and I need some help input
guidance feedback I'll say tell me why I
suck remember why I suck at this thing
why do I suck at this like how do I get
better
and when I do that it's because they
give me their honest feedback you know
when when you just ask for feedback
people will be afraid of hurting your
feelings and you won't get the full info
so I say tell me why I suck and they say
well you don't suck but
here's what you need to fix
I empower the people around me that if I
say scary difficult or hard
then I have to go up and do the thing
just because I said scary difficult to
heart I don't want to be the person who
plays small so my son particularly loves
this one right it's like Dad you did it
you said scary oh shoot okay now I have
to go off and do it what are your
trigger words what are the things that
make you stay small and then empower the
people around you to call you out on it
so that
when you don't catch it because you
won't catch it most of the time you
won't catch it but when you can't catch
it and somebody else can
not being defensive and not uh
putting our guard up and realizing that
hey this behavior is keeping me stuck
empowering the people around you to give
you the feedback to pull you out of the
Matrix so you can start turning what
subconscious to conscious
if you feel like
you're a little bit stuck
if you feel like
you know you want to do more and you're
capable of more and you want to serve
more and help more
and you know that you've got this voice
inside you that's keeping you there and
you're struggling with how do I get it
from subconscious and automatic negative
to subconscious and automatic positive
everything starts to change
you have to treat yourself like you
matter
just imagine that you were actually your
own best friend
just imagine that you came to you with
the problems that you're facing what
would you tell yourself
it's probably going to be something
loving something encouraging something
powerful something positive not the
words that you're actually using to talk
to yourself
this doesn't change in a day you know
doesn't change in an instant
it's a process
but if every day
by day you can slowly start to believe
in yourself more Empower yourself more
talk to yourself in a better way
you're going to create
a much better life for yourself and then
you can pay it forward and help others
because no matter what words you say no
matter how much you tell people to be
positive again you're here watching this
you are the most positive person you're
in your family you're pouring into other
people no matter how much words you use
what they'll be inspired by most is your
action
no matter how much you say hey love
yourself make this happen I believe in
you if they see you not believing in
yourself not taking the action you need
to take they'll never be inspired to do
it themselves either
they'll be most inspired by the actions
that you take when you're afraid and you
doubt yourself too it's time to make a
change let's make that change today when
it comes to an affirmation affirmations
can be powerful
um and for some people they're not and a
lot of people say well you know if the
the affirmation is so powerful how come
I'm not experiencing the effect the what
scientists tell us is the average human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80 000
thoughts per day some of those thoughts
are the words to the songs and they are
the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that create stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift at the very core of our
expression so we know that words are are
powerful the key to a successful
affirmation is that we must communicate
with the subconscious part of our of our
mind number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I see him about a
million times a day I said did they work
for you he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even
he didn't believe that he was worthy of
his Perfect Mate manifesting for him now
so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times that we have
lost our power and that we have no
ability to communicate with a greater
power with god with the forces around us
and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship the fundamental physics of
our relationship to our world uh have
been minced and parceled and in many
cases deleted
from the texts leaving us with a sense
that we are essentially powerless beings
and if you are powerless then you are a
victim and if you are a victim you need
a savior and that savior is coming to us
on a silver plate in terms of technology
in terms of political leaders I will
save you if you just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies in the earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality now
for me it's it's a uh it's good news
it's a beautiful message of Hope and
possibility
as a sovereign biological being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing nor has it ever faster
than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so
in um I was at the CERN super conducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the beginning of our universe and then
they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that
we are experiencing that we're living
under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant
so it's not like it's about to happen
that's it's happening right now every
atom is constantly emerging and
collapsing into that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you
you are becoming the change so you're
becoming the abundance you're becoming
uh the love the Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited
from the the religious texts in the
fourth Century by the church they took
they took out the information helping us
to understand this this deep
relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a a
form of Prayer
or prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
[Music]
well and it's powerful it's not making
something happen out there and that
means you can't blame
what's out there for your experiences I
I come from a very dysfunctional broken
family and I had to make a choice early
in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community uh as to whether or not I
would allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
uh their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right wrong good or bad but we have
a choice to make another path and when
we began as a scientist beginning to
understand these relationships gave me
the reason to think differently
and they'll also give me the reason to
test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't every day of
Our Lives we live in a world that is
incredibly complex and you have to
remember we all have a two million year
old brain
and it's not designed to make you happy
it's designed to make you survive
so it's always looking for what's wrong
so why would we allow this to be because
it's just a bad habit and so we need a
daily practice and so I want to show you
how I do this for me and I want you to
create your own system based on it this
mind serves me I don't negotiate with it
remember I told you I don't say well
I'll do this well maybe we could do it
maybe we'll jump in the water now it's
like it knows I'm not here to negotiate
when I say it we do it
that's what we want to train ourselves
to do today whenever you want to make a
change or improve something
the first place you want to prove it is
in your mental emotional state
if you do something from a pissed off
state from an exhausted state from a
frustrated state from a weak state it
won't matter what you do the thoughts
are weak when you're in a weak place the
actions are weak so the first thing
we're going to do is I'm going to show
you a simple breathing pattern
and the breathing pattern if you're
familiar with yogas like Breath of Fire
it's similar to Breath of Fire and it's
a movement what it's going to look like
is this you're going to sit up in your
chair with energy we're going to raise
our hands up as we take the air in and
then you're going to blow it out
only going to blow it out your notes and
we're going to do that over and over
again for 30 breaths you're going to do
this with your eyes closed then you're
going to drop your hands down Palms up
on your weight on your legs and you're
just going to feel whatever you feel you
might notice some tingling you might
notice a sense of peace
it might just feel relaxed and then
we'll do another three sets of ten
another thirty we'll relax and then
another so we're gonna do three sets of
thirty three sets of ten ten ten ten ten
ten ten ten ten with a break between
them when you're done with that you're
ready to Prime because it puts you in
state priming is three actions it's done
in ten minutes you can do more than ten
and many of you will enjoy it so much
you'll go longer but the reason I do 10
minutes of priming is I wanted to come
up with a daily discipline there was no
excuse not to do if you don't have 10
[ __ ] minutes for your life you don't
have a life so what we're going to do is
we're gonna do our three sets of ten
three sets of ten three sets of ten then
when their eyes closed the first three
and a third minutes of the ten minutes
is we're going to focus on three
experiences in our life that we can feel
deeply grateful for three of them and
we're not going to think I'm like oh
this this we're gonna take them one at a
time spend about a minute each and step
into that moment in your life that you
could feel grateful for it could be a
little thing or a big thing it doesn't
matter
what matters is that you go there you
know if I ask you what's it like to be
on a roller coaster and you remember
time when you're in a roller coaster and
you picture yourself in a roller coaster
over there you're going to give me a
very different feedback than if I get
you to imagine the moment you were going
over the edge and you're in the front
seat then you're going to show me a
different result you want your gratitude
to be in the front seat not an
intellectual gratitude out there so I
take three minutes
a minute each I come up with something
different every time I think of a moment
that I could feel so grateful for a
blessed moment a beautiful moment a
loving moment a sacred moment and I step
in and feel it and flood myself with the
Gratitude gratitude is the antidote to
the two emotions that mess up most
people's lives what are they anger and
what fear those are the two biggest you
cannot be grateful and angry
simultaneously that's the beauty of it
it's the antidote to anger you can't be
fearful and grateful simultaneously so
the more you cultivate and Prime
yourself for gratitude the more you can
push through anger and fear very quickly
and by the way when I do it
I usually pick two strong ones and then
I pick something really simple and I
make myself really feel the Gratitude
like the wind on my face or the smell of
the ocean if I'm doing it outside by my
house or the look on one of my
children's faces and I'll just fill that
up and the reason is
if all you do is get grateful about big
things you're going to miss most of life
after we do our breathing step one of
the three steps first the breathing then
the three steps one gratitude three
minutes roughly a minute each three
different moments you can feel grateful
for and feel it enjoy it savor it live
in it next three in the third minutes
second piece we're gonna do is you're
gonna feel the energy in you and do a
prayer or a blessing now I know many of
you are not religious I'm not suggesting
you need to be
but almost all of us know there's a
power in love
you know if God was love and we didn't
come up with all the other names for God
you wouldn't have much argument between
people so imagine that what you're going
to do is Imagine uh energy of God the
universe whatever you want to imagine
coming down into you like a white light
and breathing it down in through your
body down your legs into the Earth and
then coming back up and out again so
it's
and then comes back up and you don't
have to do this with your hands but I'm
trying to show you what the feeling is
and while you're doing this what you're
going to do during those three minutes
is you're going to give thanks and it's
like a prayer saying heal my body my
mind my emotions strengthen me make me
the best I can be strengthen my love my
passion my courage whatever it is that
you value in yourself and you feel that
happening of the three minutes I do that
for about a minute and a half and the
other minute half I then take that
energy through me and I send it in a
circle around to my children to my
family to my friends to my co-workers to
my associates to my partners to the
people I meet on the street to my
clients and so it's taking the energy
and now you might sound like woo-woo
stuff but the idea of allowing your
nervous system to heal and strengthen
just the focus of that alone for you is
strong and sending to others as well so
you can think it's all [ __ ] but try
it and decide based on the experience if
you do it a while I think you're going
to find it'll deepen that sense of
gratitude because it becomes not only
gratitude but healing is strengthening
and a gift to those you love the last
three minutes I call three to thrive
you're going to think of three things
that you really want to accomplish or
achieve but instead of like hoping it
happens or thinking about it happening
you're going to step in your mind and
experience it as if it's done you're
going to see it or feel it breathe it
celebrate it like you've already
achieved the goal what you're doing is
training your reticular activating
system and we talked about this the
other day the part of your brain that
notices things when you did you know
before you bought that car outfit you
never noticed them now you buy that car
outfit those cars and outfits are
everywhere how come because your Ras now
that your own one says this is important
I need to pay attention to this well
when you get clear what you want and you
see it as done and feel it and create it
in your mind in your heart and you
celebrate it there's a sense of
certainty then there's your body and
your reticular activated system starts
to go to work on making it happen so you
spend a minute each one of those so
basically three minutes each three and
third minutes each and we're done you
don't have to necessarily have done
anything wrong for things to get
completely out of control
it's a terrifying Doctrine but it's not
a hopeless Doctrine because it still
says that there's a way forward there's
a pathway forward and the pathway
forward is to adopt a motive being that
has some nobility so that you can
tolerate yourself and perhaps even have
some respect for yourself as someone
who's capable of standing up in the face
of that terrible vulnerability and
suffering and that the pathway forward
as far as the existentialists are
concerned is by well certainly by the
avoidance of Deceit particularly in
language but also by the adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your part
to actually Rectify them and the thing
that's so interesting about that is
there will have two as far as I'm
concerned and some of this is from
Clinical experience you know if you take
people and I've told you this and you
expose them voluntarily to things that
they are avoiding and are afraid of you
know that they know they need to
overcome in order to meet their goals
their self-defined goals if you can
teach people to stand up in the face of
the things they're afraid of they get
stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over decades-long periods what they
could be like if they were who they were
if they said if they spoke their being
forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world in a number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something I mean you can think
about this yourselves I often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying watching things on YouTube that
not only do you not want to watch that
you don't even care about that make you
feel horrible about watching after
you're done that's probably four hours
right there you know what you think well
that's 20 25 hours a week it's 100 hours
a month that's two and a half full work
weeks it's half a year of work weeks per
year and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting
fifty thousand dollars a year is a way
bigger catastrophe than it would be for
me to waste it because I'm not going to
last nearly as long and so if your life
isn't everything it could be you could
ask yourself well what would happen if
you just stopped wasting the
opportunities that are in front of you
you be who knows how much more efficient
10 times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the Pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment both of which are are are our
major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt it isn't merely that your
fate depends on whether or not you get
your act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate it's the fate of everyone that
you're networked with and so you know
you think well there's nine billion
seven billion people in the world we're
going to Peak at about 9 billion by the
way and then it'll decline rapidly but
seven billion people in the world and
who are you you're just one little dust
moat among that seven billion and so it
really doesn't matter what you do or
don't do but that's simply not the case
it's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network you're a node in
a network of course that's even more
true now that we have social media
you'll you'll know a thousand people at
least over the course of your life and
they'll know a thousand people each and
that puts you one person away from a
million and two persons away from a
billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do they're like dropping
a stone in a pond the ripples move
outward and they affect things in ways
that you can't fully comprehend and it
means that the things that you do and
that you don't do are far more important
than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but I mean if
you really ask yourself would you be so
sure if you had the choice I can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters
but I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
now when you say well nihilists suffered
dreadfully because there's no meaning in
their life and they still suffer yeah
but the advantage is they have no
responsibility
so that's the payoff and I actually
think that's the motivation say well I
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is a meaningless suffering
but you can always whine about that and
people will feel sorry for you and you
have the option of taking the pathway of
the Martyr so that's a pretty good deal
All Things Considered especially when
they are when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well with
sojournitzen figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends because that's
what happened in the 20th century
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to improve your self-confidence
every day check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you'll gain confidence by going to
a spot that makes you feel good it's
gonna be a false reality and the second
life gives you that challenge all you
want to do is go back to or what gave
you confidence is that happy spot
no